[Música]
faltou o que faz uma boa fotografia e o
que precisa aprender para fazer uma boa
foto
eu sempre gostei de kobe
muita gente gosta de kombi mas em
particular
essa história começa desde as histórias
que meu avô contava quando levava a
minha avó e seus 11 filhos para passear
e em uma véspera de natal em dezembro de
essa minha vontade ter kombi apareceu na
minha frente
em uma manobra bem louca eu vi essa como
estacionada em uma garagem de automóveis
estacionei o carro bruscamente
atravessei a br para ficar olhando e
ninguém vai me atender
fiquei lá olhando por fora até que vem o
vendedor sem muita vontade não acreditou
em mim fico reparando a minha aparência
principalmente números dreads essa
questão dos dreads uma cidade
tradicional e teve que romper muitas
barreiras assim como atender alguns
clientes que não não acredito que esse
rapaz que faz esse trabalho os pais dos
alunos da faculdade durante as
formaturas
esse foi o professor do meu filho mas
enfim não dei bola e pedir pra olhar
kombi quando eu olhei a kombi por dentro
e ela estava adaptada para viajar
eu pirei essa kombi tem que ser minha
perguntei o preço e assustei viajar é
dell ficou continua sendo um sonho
pedi para tirar umas fotos que tirei e
no outro dia fui passar o natal com a
família
mostrei como para meus tios primos
família e tal eles reconhecem um carro
velho só vai dar problema vai gastar
gasolina vai ficar parado no trânsito só
vai incomodar deixa deixe mas não tava
nem aí porque eu queria essa kombi até o
camuflado do toldo que agora está na
moda eu me inspirava
eu tive uma admiração muito grande
o exército não quis servir acaba
cabeludo skatistas mas eu quis servir no
dia do alistamento
na entrevista eu cheguei lá e fui
entrevistado pelo coronel talvez não
servir por um excesso de sinceridade mas
ele perguntou pra mim porque você quer
servir
eu falei gosto do meu país quero
defender a pátria
quero ter essa porque uma oportunidade
de vivência e ter a oportunidade de dar
três tiros de metralhadores soltar uma
granada
não passei depois ainda tentei fazer
prova da esa e tal mas enfim vi que era
outros caminhos
bom aí um primo meu policial rodoviário
tal conseguiu-o o nome do proprietário
pela placa
aí eu liguei para um amigo que também é
apaixonado por você como ele passou o
telefone e liguei para o dono
olha victor ongs incensado tal e fiquei
interessado queria vê lá melhor e tal
ele falou olha por bacana mas o ano que
vem porque agora estou de férias na
praia
aí eu contei para ele que se ele viesse
eu faria uma viagem longa até o interior
do rio grande do sul divisa brasil
uruguai no chile para prestigiar a
formatura de um primo que tinha quase
falecido no acidente ele sensibilizou e
veio e trocamos uma idéia em outro dia
ele deixou dirigia quando tirou a kombi
da garagem tiro deixou dirigir e quando
eu sentei no banco do motorista e
pilotando a kombi
olhei pelo espelho e não acabava mais
aquele veículo todo espaçoso
a sensação foi incrível olhei para ele e
falei olha negócio fechado
só que tem um porém eu não tem dinheiro
ganhou um sério pegou o telefone e ligou
para um amigo que história é essa de é
indicar alguém que pra comprar quando
que não tem dinheiro e tal daí eles
ficaram falando que ele desligou ele
aceitou
não sei o que o meu amigo falou mas eu
acredito que falou bem de mim porque
tocou bom feliz da vida eu cheguei em
casa
botei todas as coisas que eu tinha
dentro todas as coisas que tina de campo
coisa coloquei dentro e peguei a estrada
numa viagem de quase
mil quilômetros em direção ao swing mas
antes eu parei pra dormir com ela de
frente pro mar e mostrar para minha
família que tinha de hoje adquirida
kombi
bom essa viagem até o chuí eu fui sem
nunca dirigi kombi sem utilizar gps sem
map a rota eu só fui uma viagem de quase
mil quilômetros sem saber só quer chegar
no chuy pronto levei umas 20 horas mais
até de puro êxtase
nossa estou viajando de kombi road trip
é e aí eu me perdi me perdi me perder
várias vezes
e esses caminhos onde me perdia
descobrir novas histórias novas rotas
novos cenários e situações diferentes
ambientes diferentes para fotografar e
nessa viagem fui conversando com muitas
pessoas elas perguntavam o que eu estava
fazendo que esse maluco de dredd está
viajando numa kombi meio preta milho
verde
eu falei estou viajando tira umas fotos
puxa que legal mostra essas fotos que
está tirando eu mostrava as fotos que eu
tava tirando eles achavam bacana pois
como é que faz para tirar uma foto dessa
por exemplo encontra luz do pôr do sol
aí eu mostrava ensinava fazer a foto com
câmera celular e ela nas chapas que
bacana legal e isso aconteceu inúmeras
vezes durante a viagem
e esse contato com a fotografia começou
quando eu era pequeno
esse retrato foi no meu aniversário de
seis anos
era carnaval festa temática eu estava
fantasiado de índio essa foto que tirou
o meu pai e ele pintou o rosto com
button e nas costas para caracterizar
mais eu pedi para eles é uma caveira
eu nunca vi como ficou a caveira mas
quando olha esse retrato na minha parede
isso me faz lembrar muito a fotografia
memória bom aos 14 anos eu comecei a ter
contato com a fotografia de uma forma
mais avançada a minha primeira câmera
foi essa é chica muito popular na década
de 90
eu cheguei a fotografar um filme por mês
um filme
por mês quase fotógrafo profissional pra
época
durante a faculdade já trabalhando na
área e fazer alguns experimentos mais
avançados eu consegui comprar uma câmera
profissional na lógica investir processo
era cara demorado mas eu aprendi muito e
com uma câmera fotográfica de disquete
um ponto 2 megapixels eu fiz desde
fotografia de balada até catálogo de
moda
foi uma evolução e tanto bom a
fotografia foi mudando foi evoluindo
hoje não revelamos quase mais fotos
existem publicações da internet com
imagens manipulações margens imagens
verídicas imagens falsas e esse contexto
foi mantê lo na minha cabeça fiquei
pensando poxa será que eu não consigo
vincular essa história do meu contato
com a fotografia dessa da kombi dessa
história e eu fiquei pensando poxa que
eu posso fazer
aí certo dia olhei a kombi no pátio de
casa
honestamente limpando o cocô do cachorro
lá e via como esse puxa isso parece uma
câmera fotográfica
acho que isso pode virar um projeto de
fotografia pois foto combina com kombi
assim como kombi combina com foto
aí eu pensei eu olhei pra dentro dela e
viu os armários e feliz nós isso dá pra
colocar minhas câmeras ali dentro da
água colocar meus livros de fotografia e
nossa isso parece que está pronto há
como ela já estava adaptada mas do qual
eu coloquei as coisas dentro do dela
nossa ficou perfeito bom pronto já tenho
minha sala de aula ambulantes só falta
fazer a aula
aí pensei então eu vou levar essa
conduta num lugar junto à natureza eu
vou fazer uma aula de fotografia prática
aí eu subi o morro coloquei ela junto à
natureza
passei a noite lá vivenciando um momento
no outro dia convidei amigos pra ter
aula
montem uma estrutura teste em volta da
kombi e aí os amigos tiveram aulas sair
para fotografar a natureza nas trilhas
fechadas
o pessoal me estimulou muito falou poxa
isso vai dar muito certo e aí eu
desenvolvi a marca do projeto
falei com alguns com
atos um mês depois eu realizei a
primeira oficina de fotografia
itinerante na kombi foi muito legal
muito gratificante esse momento e como é
que funciona isso eu vou ao acaso assim
como foi falado
às vezes recebo convite para realizar
atividades em outros lugares e sempre o
tempo e um dia antes eu não pesquiso
rota mas limão pesquisa o endereço
procura uma referência assim não tem
armazém tal tradicional uma placa
amarela que me chama atenção porque daí
eu vou perguntando se os pontos de
referência justamente para as pessoas
que estão no caminho porque essas
pessoas esses lugares não me promovendo
as histórias as narrativas e os cenários
onde eu acrescento na minha aula
aí quando eu chego lá eu monto toda a
estrutura da kombi
assim como ela tá ali fora e tal bem com
mesas cadeiras e tal e cidadã eu faço
até um café no fogareiro para
recepcionar os alunos a eles é até o
fato de estacionar como sempre em
lugares muito inusitado sem subir
canteiros ou ela não passa na altura
enfim são várias situações
aí quando está tudo pronto a receber os
alunos vão interagindo com a kombi eles
vão entrando dentro e vamos ver nos
livros
tirando algumas elfes e assim começa um
universo que dentro dela é o minimuseu a
biblioteca
a aula começa então falando sobre a
história da fotografia contextualizando
o movimento fotográfico ou é as
histórias do projeto
ai mostra uma fotografia dando dicas de
composição os recursos das câmeras essas
coisas enfim mas a parte mais legal da
oficina é como eu estou em um lugar ao
ar livre um lugar diferente de uma sala
de aula comum eu consigo fazer a parte
prática envolvida com o contexto desse
lugar
essa parte prática ela pode ser qualquer
tema que pode utilizar a fotografia como
instrumento que pode ser desde
fotografia de natureza aliando com a
consciência ambiental ou a fotografia
mais cultural ou social ou temas mais
polêmicos como as imagens da internet
principalmente em escolas quando
trabalhamos a questão da do
compartilhamento de imagens enfim
depois dessa prática os alunos
encaminhou suas melhores fotos para o
álbum do projeto
então ele é alimentado principalmente
com as imagens dos alunos então combina
com foto ele tem esse propósito de que o
aluno ele constrói sua narrativa da
imagem
ensinar fotografia ao ar livre numa
kombi é aproximar as pessoas de uma
forma muito espontânea
uma das histórias que eu mais gosto
aconteceu numa segunda-feira de manhã na
praça doutor blumenau onde bem cedinho
quando estava estacionando a kombi
montando toda a estrutura uma humilde
senhora se aproximou e perguntou o que
eu ia fazer ali e contei para ela vou
dar uma aula de fotografia e ela nossa
que legal sempre quis aprender
fotografia mas nunca tive câmera
a minha filha ela foi embora e deixou
uma câmera mas eu nem sei se funciona
ela disse
aí olhei pra ela poxa volta aqui pega a
câmera que eu vejo se ela funciona e faz
a aula e ela não é legal mas tem que
pagar eu falei não pode então eu vou
limpar o escritório rapidinho de
trabalho eu volto para fazer aula
o tempo passou a aula já começou os
alunos todos já concentrados ali pela
metade da orla aula parece bem tímida
ela foi chegando e tal pedir com licença
para os alunos e pedir pra ver a câmera
dela já era uma câmera digital compacta
mais antiga mas aparentemente funcionava
peguei as pilhas e coloquei vi que a
câmara ligou e aí me aproximei dela e
fui mostrando os botões só quem tira
foto e aqui dá pra ver as fotos
quando eu apertei visualizador de
imagens apareceram fotos essas fotos
eram fotos da filha dela que ela não
havia há mais de cinco anos
ela aproximou do rosto e começou a
chorar
todos ficaram em silêncio
eu engoli seco e me emocionei
eu não fiz nada eu só coloquei as pilhas
na câmera
todo aquele momento foi causado pelo
poder da fotografia que é um retrato
feito de luz uma memória registrada em
escolas
a atividade do projeto é ainda mais
gratificante
a admiração das crianças pela kombi pela
fotografia e até pelo menos gredes
inspira muito porque eles são muito
curiosos eles querem escondia ser isso
viajar de kombi é fotografando um
camuflado lhes perguntam se eu sou do
exército o seu filho que eu fotografo
natureza já fotografei girafas eu já fiz
e dizer nós eles têm uma imaginação
muito fértil e eu tive a oportunidade de
realizar uma oficina de fotografia com
crianças no meu bebê indígena guarani
foi muito bacana então um movimento
transformador nas escolas é muito
satisfatório
aquelas crianças puxando o meu breve
sair numa self é um projeto independente
eu vou ao acaso em escolher um destino
para viajar já fiz viagens fotográficas
para alguns cantos do país como rio de
janeiro aqui é para tim já fui pra são
paulo que o grande do sul paraná
então já fiz viagens fotográficas e
sempre que tenho oportunidade eu para
kombi converse com alguém e tentou
realizar uma oficina de fotografia
gostaria de poder fazer isso mais mas é
muito difícil pois necessita de vários
tipos de situações mas vai dar certo
é o projeto já teve várias vários
convites pra fazer oficinas lugares e
tal
aqui fotografando em florianópolis aqui
é bom disse lúcia onde um conseguir um
enquadramento encaixar no estilo tipo
fazendo stand up em cima da kombi
aqui é a famosa e ponto turístico aqui
de blumenau da vila itoupava em fia como
também o personagem fotográfico e das
narrativas já apareceu a kombi em
exposições
já tive oportunidade de dar entrevistas
na televisão sair no jornal em algumas
revistas
mas isso não é o principal
o principal é poder compartilhar
fotografia com o maior número de pessoas
porque o que faz uma boa foto
o que precisa aprender para fazer uma
boa foto
o ensino da fotografia vai muito mais do
que a técnica ou do equipamento que
apenas um registrador de luz
a fotografia é um momento uma forma da
gente materializar a imagem do que
gostamos num registro único
ela faz parte de todo um contexto ela
precisa contar uma história e
principalmente para aquela pessoa que
vivenciou esse momento
então eu gostaria de com o projeto poder
conhecer os quatro cantos do brasil ou
quem sabe do mundo pois temos que ter um
foco
mas não é apenas ele que constrói a
narrativa da imagem
muito menos na nossa vida precisamos
todos perceber e canalizar as energias
desse campus de vitória
configurando a nossa câmera mente e
coração
observando todos os elementos que estão
ao nosso redor seja eles visuais ou não
só depende da gente
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]